[Musique]
la revue de presse avec vous julien
schell dab bonjour julien dont jean phi
la main avec bien évidemment cette
guerre en ukraine dont parle abondamment
la presse internationale parmi tous les
sujets proposés il y en a qui vous
tenait particulièrement à coeur c'est
cette guerre de l'information cette
guerre parallèle qui est à l'oeuvre dans
ce conflit wifi là mais je vous propose
de commencer par un dessin de presse du
suisse bénédicte du cadre duquel du
collectif cartoon for peace avec ce
chars couverts de journaux traitant du
conflit ukrainien objets satirique
visant à critiquer la nouvelle loi votée
il ya quelques jours par le mall le
parlement russe et qui interdit aux
médias russes et étrangers basés en
russie est bien de parler tout
simplement de cette guerre de ne pas
employer le mot guerre mais de parler
d'un conflit d'une opération militaire
les rares médias russes encore
indépendant il ya quelques jours on
était soit obligé de fermer soit de
s'auto-censurer plusieurs bureaux
étrangers notamment ceux de la bbc ou de
sienne encore ont suspendu leurs
activités pourquoi je vous parle de
style parce que cette stratégie de
maîtriser l'information elle est au
coeur de tout ce conflit militaire
provoqué par la russie la russie qui
n'hésite pas à réécrire totalement le
réel écrit le new york times dans un
article au vitriol la russie pays où
toutes les nouvelles sont fausses et où
le régime au pouvoir effectué un lavage
de cerveau de sa population les mots
sont assez forts avec ses conséquences
sur le quotidien des russes où l'on
décrit des dîners de famille qui se
termine en pugilat autour de la table
entre ceux qui d'un côté ne crois
absolument pas à une guerre en ukraine
et ceux qui essayent de les convaincre
du contraire mais cette propagande
julien puisque c'est son nom puisque
c'est comme ça qu'il faut l'appeler
fondé sur des mensonges à ce qu'elle ne
risque pas de s'effondrer comme un
château de cartes ou bien c'est en tout
cas l'avis du magazine américain foreign
policy qui rappelle que côté ukrainien
c'est un ancien comédien quitte à la
tête du pays volodymyr zen ski acteurs
de formation et surtout on l'a vu encore
ces derniers jours m de la communication
qu'il s'exprime en russe dans des vidéos
tournées au coeur de la capitale kiev
est destiné surtout à la population la
population russe le journal américain
oppose les styles des deux présidents
ukrainien d'un côté et russes de l'autre
avec volodymyr zelensky jeunes
présent sur les réseaux sociaux et de
l'autre un chef d'état donc vladimir
poutine tout puissant mais isolé et
reclus kipré enregistre ses déclarations
conclusion du journaliste américain
c'est en communiquant via les réseaux
sociaux que le dirigeant ukrainien y
parviendra peut-être à casser la
propagande russe en visant notamment la
jeunesse encore faut-il que ces réseaux
sociaux soit encore accessible en russie
au coeur de ce conflit ils y allaient
civils et notamment les enfants on
revient julien sur le bombardement de
cet hôpital pédiatrique de mario paul
dans le sud est de l'ukraine qui a
suscité de très vives critiques au sein
de la communauté internationale mais
libération parle déjà de génération
sacrifiée entre d'un côté les enfants
qui se terrent dans les abris
souterrains pour échapper aux
bombardements et ceux qui quittent le
pays et entre les deux il y a ceux qui
meurent des suites donc des bombes des
bombardements comme vous l'avez dit à
marioupol un crime de guerre avait réagi
l'union européenne depuis le début de
l'offensive russe au moins 60 et aux
enfants ont perdu la vie sans parler de
ce rappel le journal encore vivant mais
lourdement traumatisée et comment ces
enfants sont ils les en charge et bien
pour ceux qui le peuvent ils sont
évacués vers l'ouest comme la grande
ville de lviv près de la frontière
polonaise ville qui est pour l'instant
relativement épargné par les
bombardements ou les autres les enfants
sont prises en charge par des équipes
médicales déjà très saturé ce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas reste à kiev où je vous
invite à lire le récit de les yacks et
une pédiatre de 35 ans et qui raconte la
libération son quotidien fait de micro
sieste de mouvement de panique suite aux
alertes aux bombardements où se
succèdent les pleurs et les cris et des
parents la plupart des pédiatres entend
toutefois rappelle le journal rester
dans le pays auprès des enfants pour
faire leurs devoirs même s'il devient de
plus en plus compliquée a exercé en
raison notamment du manque de matériel
l'europe vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure julien qui a évoqué des crimes
de guerre commis en ukraine ce conflit a
déjà des répercussions sur le vieux
continent notamment sur le plan
économique oui c'est l'autre guerre dont
parle le quotidien la croix qui touche à
la fois l'union européenne mais surtout
la russie les deux camps s'affrontent
pour l'instant sur le terrain économique
à coup de sanctions et de contre mesures
pour les russes on parle de 300
milliards de dollars d'avoirs russe
gelée on parlait à l'instant du calvaire
subi par la population ukrainienne mais
l'édito aussi évoque le tribut qu'auront
à payer les russes et on ne parle pas là
de fermeture dans saigne de fast food
mais de possibles manque imminent de
matières premières qui sert notamment à
produire des médicaments
pardon cela pourrait coûter cher à
l'europe mais si c'était une chance pour
l'union européenne et ça c'est la
question que se pose le foreign policy
question provocatrice évidemment dans un
contexte comme celui ci magazine
canalise plusieurs décennies d'histoire
économique européenne depuis 20 ans le
vieux continent d'après le journal
semblent empêtrés dans des règles
économiques de plus en plus complexe et
surtout inefficaces explique le magazine
et on a vu quelques heures seulement
après le début de l'invasion russe est
bien le l'élan de solidarité et les
landes d'union nationale ou plutôt
européen qui a surpris beaucoup beaucoup
de monde le magazine va jusqu'à prédire
un nouvel ordre mondial économique qui
ne dépendrait plus seulement des états
unis on en est encore loin la seule
certitude à l'heure actuelle ces camps
en restant soudés c'est en restant
soudés que les européens rési réussiront
peut-être à résister aux conséquences de
cette crise sont séquence économique
conséquence pour les tic aussi notamment
en france sur l'élection présidentielle
on peut le dire oui ce qui est sûr c'est
que cette addiction est dans toutes les
têtes des électeurs d'après le parisien
il ya ceux comme à reims qui disent que
cette guerre s'arrêtera bien un jour et
d'autres qui se demandent jusqu'où
ira-t-on poutine je cite dans le texte
mais de l'avis général beaucoup
regrettent que la campagne soit passé au
second plan en raison de la guerre en
ukraine la conséquence tout simplement
est bien c'est que certains qui avaient
déjà une possible idée de leur vote
avant avant la guerre et depuis
plusieurs mois et bien tout simplement
tenté de ne pas changer de vol c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de campagne selon
eux pas de débat et donc ils ne seront
pas influencées par un quelconque par
une quelconque campagne il reste encore
un mois ou 12 candidats pour tenter de
convaincre les plus rien décider parmi
les indécis a une nouvelle fois
peut-être plus qu'aux élections
précédentes les jeunes julien qui risque
de ne pas se déplacer en nombre oui
d'après un sondage du cevipof moins d'un
jeune sur deux c'est à dire entre 18 et
24 ans envisage de ne pas voter dans un
mois en 2010 est il était 29% alors
pourquoi boot ils se votent le figaro
tente d'apporter quelques éléments de
réponse à cette question parce qu'ils se
disent apolitiques ni de droite ni de
gauche et peut-être plus grave encore
ces jeunes disent ne plus avoir
confiance du tout dans les institutions
notamment suite aux échecs selon eux des
pouvoirs publics pour essayer de limiter
les causes les effets du réchauffement
climatique il merci beaucoup julien
schell da pour votre revue de presse au
vu de presque vous vous pouvez retrouver
sur vos plateformes habituelles à
commencer par le site france24 point com